vous ne connaissez sans doute pas bjork
et islandaises ou jamiroquai ou le
système 5 hier pour être honnête moi non
plus alors allons à rennes avec car
jouer parce qu'être des nains de jardin
survolté une atmosphère de bodega en
plein hiver les nuits de raismes
s'illumine lorsque les transmusicales
souple quinze bougies et ici c'est la
musique qui allume la mèche au soleil de
minuit la première explosion simple et
cette fois bjork pour des débuts solo
m'a virtuoso
doucet
depuis france est la révélation sinclair
se donner du coeur à l'ouvragé en
répétant rue saint michel rue de la soif
pour les intimes témoin
à 20 de jeunesse tout à fait au goût du
public
et pourtant adoucir les moeurs tel est
bien le genre de message de l'une des
grandes figures des transmusicales 93
jamiroquai 23 ans 9 musiciens est une
voie unique
mais
les dizaines et des dizaines de groupes
la curiosité pour seul pluzz office nuls
à rennes on retrouve ses lettres de
noblesse celle de ville rock
y aller